my name is Bill George currently
impressed professor of management
practice at harvard business school i
was born in Muskegon Michigan well being
born in the Midwest I think I adapted
some of the Midwestern values that
tended to come with the area which I was
grown my mother came from a Dutch family
at Dutch immigrant family and we were
very much a part of her family growing
up and I think that became very much a
part of me values like frugality
integrity modesty things like that well
certainly my mother did my mother I give
a great deal of credit for raising me my
values my father traveled a great deal
as a consultant and the rest a muse on
the golf course my father gave me the
rules of how to live my mother taught me
how to live if you will and have an only
child of older parents well I can't back
to my father's imprint he wanted me to
be CEO of a major corporation even named
the company's suggested maybe coca-cola
or IBM or Procter & Gamble which is kind
of ironic if you think about it but I
had this desire to be a part of business
because I thought business could have a
great impact on the world particularly
an ethically run value centered business
which was my desire to become that kind
of business leader and even as a
teenager many of the business leaders
that I saw in those days fell far short
of what I thought leadership should be
and I was hoping to have some impact on
changing leadership but during the
course of my life
Oh